stéphanie grammond michel david
schlosser du faux bon choix
je commence avec le ch le chemin rock
sam je vous remontent les chiffres ceux
qui n'étaient pas avec nous en tout
début il ya eu un mail en six mois
d'entrée régulière par le chemin roxane
donc ça c'est vraiment forte
augmentation par rapport aux autres
années on va le voir le site r 16 17
mille
ans les actions 16000 18000 jumelles et
20000 en six mois les autres une année
complète je fais entendre monsieur
blanchet qui a réagi aujourd'hui chef du
bloc québécois à ce dossier de romain
champion revient
ya une complaisance
entre complices est faible de la part du
gouvernement et en particulier du
premier ministre quant à l'exercice du
contrôle qu'on doit faire qu'on doit
mettre en place à nos propres frontières
lorsque démonte romain en parlant à des
gens qui font le pas sachez que c'est
devenu vraiment une affaire très
profitable on va les chercher de plus en
plus au sud des états unis ces gens là
stéphanie
on ne pourra pas éternellement
laisser ça comme ça le statu quo va
devenir pénible c'est depuis des mois
depuis des années c'est un peu comme une
pièce de théâtre si on veut où tous les
acteurs ont appris leur rôle et ça
fonctionne tellement bien que
ça roule ça roulait plus lol 2 le
dernier la dernière trouvaille c'est
qu'on entend qu'il ya des
mini vans qui est qu'ils sont organisés
pour le transport à partir de la floride
est donc le problème c'est que tout ça
est tellement bien organisé mais c'est
difficile de le défaire parce que c'est
tout dépend de l'entente des tiers pays
sûrs ce des ententes canadienne des
ententes internationales qui font que le
canada s'il est si les personnes se
présentent à la douane officiel on doit
les les refuser les renvoyer aux états
unis donc ça fait en sorte que ces
gens-là passe à côté par le chemin loxam
et à ce moment là le canada n'a pas le
choix de les laisser entrer et si on
disait faire mon chemin roxane se sent
un peu comme de dire on va mettre une
roche au milieu de nos rivières en
espérant que ça aide le débit de l'eau
est malheureusement l'eau va continuer à
passer mais ailleurs donc c'est ça qui
est très difficile si on veut régler le
problème pour monter en amont à la
source est sûre ça veut dire faire des
négociations avec les états unis mais
évidemment les états unis ils ont pas
vraiment davantage à négocier avec nous
parce que ce point e qui vivent le
problème est plutôt le canada parce que
les migrants viennent chez nous et non
pas l'inversé a lancé pour ce qu' on est
dans une situation assez complexe on
croyait il ya quelques mois qu'il y
aurait des négociations qui mènerait à
une solution puis finalement pas
vraiment alors eh oui on en est toujours
au même point justin trudeau m'avait dit
dans une entrevue au mois d'avril
dernier où avril mars mars avril mai jeu
revue de printemps que il reconnaissait
que c'est un problème qui est en train
de négocier
michel david ça peut bouger beaucoup
mais là les le nombre de passeurs et
deux migrants amant
oui pour les chiffres sont éloquents sa
remontée j'ai l'impression que ça va
aller en augmentant encore monsieur
trudeau je comprends que c'est compliqué
de négocier avec les américains mais un
moment donné je pense que le canada peut
suspendre de façon unilatérale cette
entente là c'est sûr que ça fera pas de
faire des américains tel point qu'on se
demande même si aucune complaisance des
américains envers les passeurs qui les
aident dans le fond à canaliser le flot
des migrants vers le canada parce que
j'imagine que il ya quand même ces gens
là se parlent si on est capable de faire
des entrevues avec des passeurs
j'imagine que l'on pourrait aussi
s'organiser pour les débusquer la police
le j'entends il n'y a aucune volonté du
côté américain c'est clair et à partir
de ce moment là je pense le canada va
être obligé de quitte à froisser un peu
les américains
d'agir maintenant est ce que monsieur
trudeau ou d'autres
tawaf ça fait un peu leurs affaires que
ça passe par québec parce qu'à peu près
tout le monde passe par le québec plutôt
que de passer ailleurs je ne veux pas
leur faire de procès d'intention mais on
n'a pas l'impression qu'ils en une
grande préoccupation passe pour preuve
le même secteur à l'extérieur du québec
christian
suicide en août je pense que non
seulement le canada + 6 mai doit
suspendre maintenant si c'est une route
qui est mondialement connu si tu
commerce a en fait d'un migrant c'est
totalement inacceptable c'est un gros
manque de respect sauf pour les
québécois puis que ça encourage du
préjugés à l'égard de l'immigration et
avant l'été le premier ministre à france
soir fait une sortie très sentie sur ce
sujet il y avait été absolument pas
approuvé par le cno publique québécoise
très bien pensante qui nous et qu'on
pouvait rien faire c'était compliqué que
ça nuire à la réputation du canada c'est
honteux grand-voile envers des bons
sentiments lui ait des gens qui se font
exploiter un site e commerce est très
bon le reportage de radio-canada là
dessus donc il faut moi je trouve
suspendue maintenant on peut le faire un
gouvernement et s'ouvrait la protection
des frontières c'est le premier rôle de
l'état je n'en reviens pas de la
mollesse de l'opinion qui peut publique
québécoise en trop dans ce dossier là
c'est clair qu'on sent pas de volonté
politique à la crise et aux 23 que vous
êtes un peu la même chose je signale
quand même
mais vous aviez des mots plus durs
d'enfermer sont fermés maintenant ce
qu'on peut le faire si ce que je vois en
fédérale peut le voir ses quarante mille
personnes par année
non mais moi je pas là car que tu m'as
dit d'accord les gens disent c'est
compliqué c'est pas vraiment que c'est
le truc le plus québécoise devrait et
j'espère qu'on va parler peut-être au
débat ce soir je suis à l'époque gabriel
nadeau-dubois vezza c'est très compliqué
tout terrain ou au débat la semaine
prochaine bon comme québécois ça me
choque beaucoup de contrôles très bien
ok c'est noté c'est noté le parlons-en
de la campagne électorale je vous montre
un premier tableau que je montrais régis
labeaume vient de second intentions de
vote générales partout sur le territoire
du québec monsieur legault 38 c'est une
une légère baisse de 4 points 1 point de
plus pour madame anglade vous le voyez
deux points de plus pour me dubois 18 17
15 et 11 pour le parti québécois de
manière générale puis je vais vous
montrer sherbrooke après je vous soit
encore plus intéressant mais de manière
générale
qu'est ce qu'on peut en dire michel
david c'est que ça pas bouger tant que
ça en du monde fera bouger de 4 points
et mais à partir du moment où les quatre
points que la cac a perdu ce répartis
presque également entre les quatre
autres partis de l'opposition cela
change pas grand chose en terme de en
termes de projection de comptes et ça
alors je pose c'est que monsieur legault
doit être terriblement inquiets il
faudrait pas qu'il faudrait que ça
arrête un moment donné je pense que ça
dénote d'une fort qu'eux
et ça ne pouvait que des cendres je
pense aussi que les gens sont pas très
admiratif de la campagne de monsieur
legault qui honnêtement c'est pas ça
mayenne mais il n'y a rien de dramatique
là dedans ce qui est intéressant
peut-être comprend parler plutôt de la
plus petite à 7 voire vraiment qui va
former l'opposition officielle il ya
effectivement des luttes qui sont
intéressantes un peu partout on va on va
en parler mais premier tour de table sur
la lure général et c'est ce petit recul
de monsieur legault stéphanie oui mais
peut-être qu'il ya des gens qui ont
sanctionné monsieur legault quand même
pour les les gaffes kill kill qui le
faites pendant la campagne c'est ses
sorties sur les migrations bon à savoir
mais évidemment c'est pas d'espoir recul
qui est dramatique mais qui changeront
probablement pas le fait qu'ils risquent
d'avoir 100
sièges à l'assemblée en fait ça va
peut-être seulement augmenter la
distorsion
électorale où on se trouve à avoir
quelqu'un qui seulement 38% des voix
mais qui se retrouvent avec 40% des
sièges ce qui est tout à fait inusité
mais sinon ce qu'il va être intéressant
évidemment ça va être de voir les
libéraux veulent et les solidaires qui
sont à peu près au coude à coude en ce
moment je pense que ça va être un peu le
tas qui va être capable de faire sortir
le vote comme on dit parce que pour pour
les solidaires le défi c'est de faire
voter les jeunes qui qui sont bons c'est
on le sait il va en fait deux fois moins
le taux de participation est deux fois
moins élevé que les personnes plus âgées
donc est-ce qu'ils vont être capables de
les convaincre d'aller voter puis pour
les libéraux baisse qu'ils vont être
capables d'aller convaincre les
allophones et puis les anglophones
d'aller d'aller aux urnes ainsi qu'à la
dernière campagne il y avait eu bien de
la difficulté et le savez peut-être
encore pire parce que ben avec les
tergiversations de dominique anglade là
sur à propos de la langue ça à froid
c'est pas mal les anglophones puis-je
posture que les parties anglophone qui
sont nés à voler convaincre davantage
d'aller voter et on voit que les seuls
endroits où la iv n'est pas en avance
c'est dans la région c'est à montréal
christian clairement parce que partout
d'ailleurs c'est une domination de la
cac moi je peux plus de relation des
choses parce que la cac qui ont fait
évidemment tous les lecteurs
francophones moi cela dit je trouve que
4 points c'est beaucoup au jeu trop pour
la quête s'est pas mis la banque en
baisse surtout qu'on est juste à lui
campagne puisque c'est le début d'une
tendance
j'ai encore beaucoup de gens qui sont
indécis et on se tâte la caq domine
domine de même 38 pour ça c'est pas tant
que ça c'est parce que évidemment ceux
qui votent pas pour la 4 sont divisés
entre plusieurs parties donc ça confirme
qu'il y avait des choses qui restent
possibles et à la place de monsieur
legault bon je dis pas que je serai
désespérée du tout mais je sentis
frustrés c'est ce que ça bouge 4% moi je
trouve ça beaucoup pour être franc la
marge d'erreur mais comme pourcentage
c'est pas rien et c'est clair qu'il ya
du mouvement on le sent que zuma elle
est intéressant cette trempe haguenau
comme la plupart des campagnes de toute
façon tout reste possible un cliché de
dire ça mais tous à peu près pas pour la
deuxième place tout reste possible tout
reste possible en totalité ou même à la
limite peut-être que le go pour la
[Musique]
deuxième place vous disiez course
intéressante pour la deuxième place
parce que le 18 17 pour les intentions
de vote sur le vote libéral et plus
concentré certains endroits mais bref
c'est intéressant oui mais la pollution
c'est paradoxalement ce la position du
parti libéral est plus solide dans la
mesure où ces châteaux forts du west
island là je parle pas de ce qui
pourrait perdre
odense ans de montréal et à laval je
pense que c'est château fort disons sont
suffisamment nombreux pour lui permettre
de conserver son statut d'opposition
officielle faudrait vraiment que québec
solidaire face des beaucoup de gains et
ligue 1 québec solidaire vont être
difficiles à faire ça va être super
enfants ça va être vraiment le départ
par la peau des fesses je peux
pour parler tantôt de cherbourg ben
justement allongée à sherbrooke parce
que c'est un bel exemple d'abord faut
pas qu'ils en perdent 2 vous dites pour
pour récupérer dans leur rêve être
opposition du ciel faut qu'ils gagnent
des circonscriptions ce qui est parfait
et qu'ils en perdent pas et qu'ils en
perdent pas bien voilà le coach
sherbrooke où il y avait eu un sondage
coulé par la cac qui montrait caroline
saint-hubert saint-hilaire en avoir
voici un autre sondage notre firme pour
la tribune qui montre au contraire que
kristine labrie est en avance là ça
ressemble extrêmement sur le tas 2 à
cherbourg c'est peut-être moi ma
circonscription chouchou le ca va
montrer si la caq arriva à déloger
québec solidaire ce sera quelque chose
c'est fanny oui c'est sûr et certain
entre eux ça montre que la caq est pas
prête à voile et dans tous les coins
pour aller chercher tous les tous les
gains possibles et 60 et 1
d'envoyer une candidate vedette comme
madame st-hilaire contre contre houston
les mairies et ça ça va être ça va être
très serré mais encore là je dirais la
même chose ça va peut-être se jouer sur
la participation
parce que là en ce moment il ya encore
beaucoup d'indécis aussi joyent un
sondage qui donnait 42% de personnes qui
pourraient changer d'avis tout est pas
joué et il faut encore faut-il que les
gens aillent voter donc sherbrooke est
une ville où il ya beaucoup de jeunes
beaucoup d'étudiants oui quand on leur
demande pour qui vous votez peut-être
qu'ils disent québec solidaire mais ce
qu'ils vont à ce que l'on dit est ce
qu'ils vont y aller pour vrai et on voit
que oui les jeunes sont très largement
favorables à q s mais les plus âgés sont
davantage favorable à la cac donc si ce
sont eux qui est qu'ils vont voter ça va
peut-être faire la différence
oui christian
c'est vrai que pour québec solidaire il
peut avoir des espoirs entre autres
l'ajout sur boxer très clair on veut que
le parti n'est clairement plus juste un
parti le montréalais du plateau on est
rendu à autre chose
le parti québécois aussi peu peut-être
provoquer des surprises moi je trouve je
sens un patient fait pour le st pierre
plamondon j'ai quand même beaucoup de
gens qui se noient cpq disparaît c'est
le seul parti qui parle de larmes que
vraiment franchement du français ça peut
être problématique est l'autre élément
dans cette campagne en fait au départ de
nîmes entre vous c'est carrément avec du
lin le parti conservateur a séduit en
fait qui brassait les cartes qui changer
les choses je suis un homme a des
problèmes on en parle quand même de jour
patrice je trouve toutes les histoires
sur les écoutes payer tout ça c'est
clair que c'est selon la rsr être
capable entre tête au débat ce soir de
dépenser 7 puis de dépasser son groupe
de convaincus des gens qui sont déjà
convaincus en fait de morts mais avait
un potentiel plus grand donc ce concept
dont on parle on parle de double mais je
trouve que bien des choses qui sont
possibles dans cette campagne à la fin
du récit vous disiez ça christian parce
qu'il faut pas donner l'impression que
tout est joué et tout est fait au dos et
m'a bel aspect si jamais l'improbable se
produit pour regarder la casse est là
parce que j'avais dit que peut-être il
pourrait être minoritaire j&j n'importe
quoi
[Rires]
ce qui est vrai parce que là c'est qu'il
faut
il faut il faut se méfier des des
projections par exemple je voyais je
regardais juste pour le plaisir après
avoir vu le sondage dans sherbrooke les
projections du sud qui avec 125 ou dans
sherbrooke on donne nos relativement
enfin on attribue à la cac qui la même
chose d'ailleurs dans abitibi or c'est
projection de son fait à partir de
sondages plus nationaux et on comprend
que c'est une formule mathématique mais
quand on arrive sur le terrain là c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose on n'est
plus dans les règles mathématiques ne
sait pas exactement ce que toucher les
électeurs dans des cours de la campagne
par exemple en abitibi est ce que la
fonderie horne doivent vraiment être
déterminante je pense que ça va jouer
beaucoup en faveur de cuers le brevet
vous mais moi je pense que non justement
pire parce que je pense que beaucoup de
gens qui n'ont pas parlé à haute voix à
moins qu'ils disent de la chez nous et
ça va peut-être aidé la caq un ancien
derrière ça c'est ironique ancien député
libéral tout à fait conseiller municipal
à roubaix alors la dynamique régionale
mai
gilles fournier c'est je lui dis souvent
mais en anglais ordonné en ont les
projections de sièges faut se méfier de
ça comme la peine c'est parce que ça ça
peut encore bouger c'est fanny
effectivement c'est sans dire que tout
va se transformer ben oui ça se dégager
et les débats même pas eu lieu moi je
pense que les gens avant de toute façon
avant la fête du travail les gens
n'avaient pas la tête à ça et vous
oubliez bien des gens qui ont suivi du
coin de l'oeil il ya cinq parties une
multitude de promesses d'engagement long
entraînement sérieux dans le crunch
parce que avec les débats il ya
peut-être beaucoup plus de monde qui
vont dire ok le foyer questions qui vont
se faire une tête qui vont donc et puis
c'est dans les derniers jours peut-être
que les gens vont vont se décider mais
encore beaucoup donné ces bombes très
bien un petit mot sur le parti
conservateur du canada qui finalement
s'est excusé je vous montre et par tweet
les gens ont dit aujourd'hui certes week
a été rédigé par un robot c'est amusant
le parti conservateur du canada on va le
voir s'excuse pour un message texte
automatiques envoyés plus tôt
aujourd'hui membre du parti dans la
circonscription de richmond arthabaska
mais serait en fait le parti disait
demandez lui qu'il démissionne parce
qu'il tourne dos à la lutte contre
l'inflation qui c'était et c'est bon on
en est où c'est la politique séance et
les règles du jeu c'est comme ça on a
l'impression que les excuses ont été
rédigées par un robot aussi oui parce
que je trouve que les conservateurs ne
me suis pas rallié il commence mal en
fait la leur campagne au québec audrey
qui comprennent pas ce qu'est le québec
québec et une culture politique
fondamentalement modérer les
conservateurs qui existe au québec ni en
sommes si un vieux fond bleu c'est pas
en radicalisant américaine or la façon
de monsieur diouf s'est comporté à
l'égard d'alain weill est ce vraiment un
manque de courtoisie ces paquets
il reste une demi heure c'est important
ce qui est paru il ya un message qui
mario québec on dirait qu'ils
comprennent parce que si j'ai avec la
gagne michèle ouimet je pense que c'est
une erreur manifestement derrière un
robot on a l'impression des fois que ce
poignet vue l'humain il me et un peu
robotique dans dans ses réactions
écoutez on a réduit je pense laisser
monsieur monsieur
yes digéré sa défaite pendant un certain
temps il se représentera probablement
pas comme indépendant de toute façon et
c'est inutile je pense parce que les
consommateurs vont vouloir récupérer ce
côté-là de blessés les supporteurs de
monsieur reyes qui sont nombreux dans
son comté il est très très apprécié et
je pense vraiment que c'est une erreur
grave
le plan c'est un peu importe qu'on croit
tradition d'avoir quitter si vite son
organisateur qui étaient respectés de
chez plusieurs conservateurs au québec
stéphanie une autre fois c'est terminé
je n'ai plus de temps à très bientôt
vous 3 merci beaucoup au revoir merci